[Applause]
hello everyone I'm Sarah Harry and as I
mentioned we would you to have Nicole
Sullivan here but due to health reasons
she can't play out to be here with us I
have the honor of filling in her stead
and let's all wish her huge we're sure
the best in her recuperation this
conference has a very special place in
my heart and when the organizers asked
me to this early this week to Stefan I
was really honored this has been a
phenomenal day as I think Luke and all
the testee and I'd like to can we all
please start with giving a huge huge
huge round of applause to the wonderful
organizers of the conference and all the
volunteers that have made us happen over
the last few months
[Applause]
so this is now the sixth year of CSS
can't be you this photo is from 2013
September 30 the first CSS conf
EU it was much smaller in terms of venue
and numbers of people that it was the
same in essence bringing people with an
interest exterior city about CSS
together in one space exchanging ideas
learning something new how did it all
begin just a few months prior the
first-ever CSS comp based in the US
Nicole Sullivan was an organizer with
the aim to address the gap in conference
space there are already conferences to
pick they're already the focus on
JavaScript or design and they were great
but they didn't have CSS developers they
didn't have those topics talked about it
was something missing from their CSS
comp us is born and one of the attendees
of this event
Chrissa came to Berlin and a plan to
bring that conference to Europe and just
a few months later he was here
hello can hear me yes thank you
[Applause]
great so so back in 2013 first ever
conference and and now six years later
six events later I should say we're here
what have we achieved throughout the
years they've been so many fascinating
talks the topics talked about and share
to a wider audience from new
specifications such as CSS grid and
variable fonts to CSS animation to new
developer tools and techniques for
writing CSS such as CSS and jeaious
there's a wealth of content that's
available in the back catalogue of
conferences and videos online these
videos are now available for developers
and would-be developers to watch learn
from and be inspired one of my favorite
aspects of this conference is the
scholarship program for people who
otherwise wouldn't be able to attend
over the years and amazing 166 people
have received scholarships to attend
this conference for many recipients of
that scholarship is the first time
they've been able to take part in the
broader developer community inspired by
this main conference CSS classes has
been offered in multiple cities Berlin
Hamburg Prague and suit to be an
Amsterdam a way to introduce people to
programming via CSS whether you're a
beginner or have been programming for
years the ethos of CSS comp remains the
same to welcome people into web but it's
become a global movement CSS comp us
Australia Norway and Argentina Asia and
sivan some upcoming ones in beautiful in
Colombia from the start
CSS con tu has had a open call for
proposals this means that anyone no
matter their background or relative
experience could have a shot of being on
stage two years ago I gave my very first
conference talk on the stage
at that point I'd only been a developer
for about a year and half I didn't know
much about confident speaking or how to
write an abstract for a tech event and
when it came to deciding on a talk and
helping refine an abstract polishing the
talk every stage is able to get support
and encouragement from different members
of this community how did I meet those
people
it was during breaks during the events
conferences meetups asking questions on
Twitter sharing my interest to learn
asking for advice so keep in touch with
the people here not here today for the
first time if you heard a great
community lightning talk drop them a
message afterwards if there's a speaker
who's inspired you to try out something
new share that with them and more widely
the connections you've made the
relationships you've built today will be
invaluable it can be incredibly helpful
to hear about people's experiences I
have a challenge for you what do you
have to offer if you're a web developer
maybe it's a half hour chat talking
about what your job is like that could
help a person considering a change in
their career have a really clear idea of
what opportunities are available to them
and how they can achieve their goals if
you're a native English speaker maybe
offer to edit a talk to abstract the
seminars if you're brand new to using a
tool or a library sharing your
experience about how it was just to use
that can be great for the main Tanners a
fresh perspective
Rachel Andrew mentioned this morning
have feedback from you to the CSS
working group of hours vendors can be
really work useful but the development
of tech if you find it stressful talking
to people at events that's fine as well
you can share your advice in blog posts
maybe or maybe briefly on a credit
Twitter dick Q&A you have your unique
perspective
and being able to share that with others
is a wonder often who we talk about
community of web developers designers
and more but what does the CSS community
mean here it could just mean having a
common interest but is it superficially
just that we write CSS what could it be
more than that what creates that slate
sense of belonging having a supportive
place my view that it's something we all
have a part in whether we've been on web
development for decades or whether we're
just starting to explore it right now
many technical fields have their areas
of tension and CSS isn't an exception I
want to examine some things that I've
noticed that aren't liking so well some
things that can be jarring some things
that we can reflect on over the past
couple of years has been a swell of
argue pitting two approaches against one
another your ask the picker site are you
with us or against us it's pretty much
as though you're going into battle right
as though if you should be part of a
clique a group have a part of your
identity supporting one particular way
of thinking on one hand they're stuck in
the past using CSS and J's is the future
how can they not see how it solves so
many issues on the other all they can't
be bothered to learn how to use the
Cascade if they're not worth our time
what would it look like if we examine
the emotional way we give these
technical implications implementations
and that we chose to act differently
we've been having this argument for
years and it's led to hostility and
division it's time to move on and find
our path forwards all tools have their
pros and cons we should be able to
listen to each other respect one another
and move on from there
another long-standing issue that likes
to focus on is this there's this
perceived hierarchy where in the
industry knowledge of CSS isn't often
considered as important as JavaScript in
the same way that front-end is often not
considered as important as back and work
such as note as Ivana McConnell said on
the stage two years ago there's a
hierarchy problem this constructed
hierarchy means people who are C's
people who see a specialist often played
less than JavaScript specialists career
progression within organizations are
often stunted a JavaScript specialist
can gain a seniority quite quickly or as
the CSS specialist often needs to go
above and beyond to prove the expertise
is just as valuable what can we do to
change this
it'll take a concerted effort on behalf
of us all the language you use when
talking about expertise in spaces like
this online in meetups in offices it's
important to pay attention to this note
what assumptions you're making will all
work assumptions you're hearing others
make and then act on changing that it's
only by respecting others expertise is
valid can we get rid of these false
hierarchies of importance
we have in the space missing talks over
the community lounge as well as talks on
stage when we leave here it's not just
with a pocket full of stickers and
badges as nice as well
it's experiences that we take away and
that inform us how we can step forwards
inclusion is going out of your way to
make a space welcoming to other
individuals it's listening to them about
what they need and acting on it in this
industry we talk about inclusive design
ensuring our websites we build are
accessible and don't form barriers to
people well about our own tech spaces
physical spaces like this conference we
have live captions to enable those with
hearing and parents to be able to
participate in real time at the
conference we have a scholarship scheme
that enables this space to be attended
by those who otherwise can afford it
the inclusion doesn't just stop at these
doors it's about how we write our open
source libraries to welcome people who
don't have English as a native language
it's about how we enforce codes of
conduct online to ensure there's a clear
understanding of expected behavior it's
about ensuring those from marginalized
groups aren't excluded
it's about respecting others often those
of us in the US or Europe Center
ourselves intact this means of an urban
so focused here every year people
expected a speakers to conferences in
Europe and the u.s. denied visas to
speak due to political circumstances we
should be using the privilege that we
have to elevate others it's about being
curious fishing boundaries learning why
things are the way they are proposing
new ways of thinking communicating with
each other across the traditional
boundaries of dev designer browser
engineer spec proposer expertise isn't
something that necessary takes years to
achieve sometimes it can be the new
joiner to the fields who gives the most
insightful critique and pushes the
boundaries of what is the received
wisdom this is about inspiring a new
generation of web developers and
revitalizing the space for those already
in the industry
building community it starts with a
shared interest in our topic in our case
CSS but it grows to be so much more than
that
it's bringing people together whether in
physical spaces like this one or in
digital spaces online
it requires ensuring that there's mutual
respect inclusivity and a platform for
sharing expertise there are many ways to
do this take inspiration from this
conference and others talk to people
about what they need
there isn't being served by current
events and online spaces what is left is
for you to come together to build your
community
thank you CSS comfy
[Applause]
[Music]